the armed wing of Hamas says that it
fired a barrage of rockets at Tel Aviv
on Saturday let's get more on this with
Alan Fisher who is L For Us in occupied
East Jerusalem Alan what more can you
tell us about this
attack well 40 missile alerts overnight
all in Central and Southern Israel
Israeli Army Radio has said in the last
couple of hours that 10 missiles were
fired from northern Gaza and that comes
just hours after the Israeli Prime
Minister said his determination was to
completely demolish Hamas and the
Israeli Army had claimed that it had
essentially military domination over
Northern Gaza so this will be
embarrassing for the Israelis and also
undermine the confidence that people
have that this operation is close to
achieving its goals now these are the
first attacks since November the 20th
and they will be concerning for the
Israelis the Iron Dome missile system
was fired but one missile failed and and
it landed very close to Tel Aviv there
was one person injured with minor
shrapnel but there's an investigation
underway to find out how the system
actually failed and we also hear that
there was Heavy fighting in Gaza
overnight and Israeli Army has in the
last hour or so worn people living in
canun in certain areas in canun to start
moving from there because there will be
more military operations around there in
the coming
hours Alan Fischer there for us in
occupied East
Jerusalem